here's the thing i like you i know your
diagnosis complicates things but i don't
care i mean
do you like me yes i do even though i
don't have
cancer make your move romeo
most teenagers feel like they're
invincible not the superman kind of
invincible
the kind of invincible that tricks you
into thinking tomorrow might be a better
day to start chasing your dreams
we've been through this just breathe you
are my best friend so you are morally
obligated to say nice things to me
everybody else out there is not my best
friend if everyone else doesn't like it
then they're idiots and while there's a
lot that i don't know at my age
what i do know is this we all have
limited time
tell me something you never told before
before i walk through
the door i adore you i adore you i
do how are you i'm off chemo is it
because it worked or
or i do
what you're facing is scary but you get
to decide
what matters most now never give
up the front door are you writing a song
hello i was thinking it might be cool if
we did something that was just ours
zach have you looked on youtube you have
20 000 views
you should be happy i thought this is
what you wanted it doesn't really matter
what i want because it's not gonna
happen
it's not fair please stop i have nothing
to give you no rings
no future nothing there's so much in
there that the world needs to hear
what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
this is insane just breathe
[Music]
it's my favorite time
in the end i just want to make people
happy i zachary zobiak i'm asking you
yes please for as long as i can
because what some people take for
granted others are fighting for
and believe me i'm a fighter
you